[Applause]
Your Majesty your royal highness
mr. president excellencies ladies and
gentlemen I accept the Nobel Prize for
peace at a moment when 22 million
Negroes of the United States are engaged
in a creative battle to end the long
night of racial injustice I accept this
award on behalf of the civil rights
movement which is moving with
determination and a majestic scorn for
risk and danger to establish a reign of
freedom and a rule of justice I refuse
to accept the view that mankind is so
tragically bound to the starless
midnight of racism and war that the
bright day break of peace and
brotherhood can never become a reality I
refuse to accept the cynical notion that
nation after nation must spiral down a
militaristic stairway into the hail of
nuclear annihilation I believe that on
unarmed truth and unconditional love
will have the final word in reality